so if we catch light to them again we'll
be back there shortly but in the
meantime the alleged assault on the
Kremlin is not the first time that
Moscow has accused Ukraine of carrying
out an attack on Russian soil so let's
talk about this a little bit more and
I'm joined here by former air Vice
Marshal Sean Bell so Sean tell us a
little bit about this drone strike on
the Kremlin remind us what happened and
How likely is it that Russia's claim
that Ukraine is essentially behind it
How likely is that to be true yeah
Tuesday night Wednesday morning that's
when this dramatic footage was first
revealed apparently a drone strike on
the Kremlin Russia immediately blamed
Ukraine and has subsequently blamed
America and anybody else they can point
their finger off of course Ukraine is
absolutely denied that it's got anything
to do with them but it's worth close to
scrutiny as to exactly why it was
probably not Ukraine um Ukraine has done
a number of attacks on Russian soil but
just over the border and normally when
they do them they're playing with
military position and with great
dramatic effects this is the example of
the Kurtz Road Bridge which was taken
out if you remember in October this was
no minor explosion this took out the
bridge for several months as a result
and if you also look at the sevastopol
oil facility which was only last week
there were 10 drones involved in taking
this out Russia claims to shot down
eight of them two evidently got through
but once again the point is it's a
dramatic effect on the ground and that's
not the DNA of this Kremlin strike at
all which looks like a little minor
explosion just above the the roof of one
of the buildings so if it's not Ukraine
behind it who else could it be well it
could be resistance fighters in the city
the trouble is um that this is a
fortress Kremlin is is an absolute
Fortress in terms of air protection and
it will be a suicide mission for anybody
trying to do this from locally and if
you're going to do a suicide mission you
want to have a better effect on this so
it looks almost certainly it wasn't that
or it's a Russian false flag operation
um who else would have actually been
able to get a slow-moving drone through
all the complex defenses and actually
get it to attack the building why also
would they plan to miss the target if
you look at the Drone footage slowly the
Drone actually doesn't actually impact
the building at all it goes slightly
past it explodes above it looks a big
flash but actually look at the smoke
plume it's a relatively small explosion
and it hasn't seemed to have done any
lasting damage to the roof at all and
thirdly it's interesting that Russia
normally struggles with its media
response to these sorts of things it
takes a few days for you to come
coherent this time it was a unified
response it was very clear that it was
blaming Ukraine almost like they were
expecting it to happen so if it was
Russia why
two main reasons probably that would
answer that why question one of which is
most military analysts think Russia is
struggling on the battlefields will be
pushed back by Ukraine in the spring
offensive and therefore expecting some
sort of false flag operation within
Russia which would justify pulling their
military resources back to the mother
Homeland to actually defend Russian
population and therefore justify
proactively why they bring it back in
um but also the Victory Day celebration
is on the 9th of May at the moment
around that's a mark in the Russian
Victory over Nazi Germany several of the
local parades have actually been
canceled ostensibly because the Russian
power thinks they don't have the crowds
being vulnerable to attack from Ukraine
which seems highly implausible but most
likely it's because of the immortal
regiments these are normal Russians who
walk along as part of the parade
carrying pictures of the loved ones that
they've lost in a war if they were
joined on that parade by people who've
lost loved ones in Ukraine then that
could significantly enhance the crowd so
we can actually exposed the huge numbers
of losses that Russia sustained on the
battlefields that's not something the
Russian authorities will have wanted so
the explosion could justify canceling
the parade or at least curtailing the
honest answer is though we don't know
what's happened but what looks most
likely is this or some sort of staged
event however unbelievable that does
appear the most likely reason for this
attack fascinating Sean thanks very much
indeed